yo
what's up guys we have a million
subscribers I'm a little late to this
but I was in Disney World at the time
that I crossed a million and I was like
well I've got to do something to
celebrate with my fans you know for
crossing a million subs I got to do
something to celebrate with my fans for
crossing a million subscribers it's
crazy but why in vertical why not
invertible
um but yeah so this is a it's a pretty
monumentous occasion i mean crossing a
million is a pretty huge milestone uh
it's not 1 million um yeah it's pretty
wild man
hashtag rob corn yeah so um you know me
crossing a million subscribers was not
something that I did on my own you know
a lot of it was done or really you know
a good amount of it was done because um
you guys have been so supportive you
guys have been astronomically supportive
in terms of my channel and and what we
do and the whole nine yards and so I was
trying to figure out a way to give back
to my fan base when we did that whole
you know April giveaway where we get
away comics and that's cool give me a
week I wasn't bad you know giving away
something that people can get anywhere
you know it's not necessarily a bad
thing uh but which by the way I think
we're gonna turn this in like a Q&A but
uh winter thank you congratulations you
talented some of them that's right
family-friendly YouTube so I was trying
to think of a way to give back to you
guys and then it occurred to me it
occurred to me like we call ourselves
the Rob core right right the Rob horn
yeah well I've got this
got this little thing here you know and
I wonder what this is and what this
thing is
yeah um
wonder what I could possibly be
what's this prize you think I should
show you should I tell you no I mean
this is a wow it looks like a ring it
looks like a ring with a lantern
insignia on it
I mean that's cool isn't it like a ring
like a Rob core ring right and wouldn't
you know it
I've got like 13 more of these things
I've got like more of these things and I
kind of feel like it would be a good
idea to give them away I think it'd be a
good idea to give them away so that's
what we're gonna do it is not a dime bag
so that's what we are going to do we are
gonna give away Rob core rings yes and
so the winners that's the legendary
forbidden ancient one million year old
rock quarry
yes winter it is so we are going to give
it away now
ah I do not remember what email address
I use before one second I cannot
remember the email address that I used
when you design house if we need to sign
back in so because of that individuals
who win this ring how many of you guys
follow me on Twitter because on my
Twitter page and I shall go ahead and
give you guys the explanation right now
we have our own whole little shindig at
the moment okay so Rob's giveaway at
gmail.com that is the email address you
need to email as a matter of fact I will
put that in the description right now of
this live stream there we go
awesome um Francis and Nadal Wow
notice me Robson PI then watching all
your stuff through the good times and
the rough patches I appreciate that
that's that's a really really momentous
that's huge that's that's pretty big I
really appreciate that
because we've had some rough patches on
this fungus chat booklet we've had some
rough patches on this channel alright uh
let's see oh my god if I can type um
okay so so here's here's a here's the
other thing here because I mean we can
turn this to do a Q&A if you guys want I
can just answer questions but there is
also something they don't want to talk
to you guys about as well and that is
really kind of like the you know where
my channel is and in the direction that
it's going in and the reason why is
because of the fact that I cannot sign
into my own damn account really what is
going on with Google Google's losing his
mind anyway this will be in the in the
description okay here we go cool it's
not letting me see
this thing's being a pain in the ass I'm
sorry guys
YouTube's being a hassle you think
YouTube would have it together by now
but I don't know maybe it's just me Rob
man Congrats keep up the great content I
appreciate it
you watch the five hour Civil War then
okay so here's something that I've been
I've been trying to think of for a while
or at least been trying to work on for a
while and that is the idea of the x-men
um one of the things that I use whenever
I go through and I begin you know I look
at YouTube videos on my channel I try to
figure out what it is that you guys do
and don't like um I look at a
combination of views and comments and
for me why is it not letting me sign out
your word there's not letting me sign
out of my own account
um I look at the using comments hold on
we missed a guy I helped you understand
the comic oh great late Bolton thank you
that's that's awesome how to underline
Magneto we're actually the next video
that we do the one that's coming out
tomorrow is actually Batman getting the
venom Samiha
but anyway um so one of the things that
I use to determine what it is that you
guys do and don't like really our
combination of comments and views on a
video I will upload a video and I'll
look at the the views that it gets in
the first 48 hours and that'll tell me
okay do you guys care about it or you
guys don't care about it and I will
upload a I will upload I don't know I'll
look at the comments you know in
determine what it is that you guys do
and don't like based on what it is that
you say what I've noticed recently is
that you guys do not really seem to care
about all-new all-different marvel you
guys really do not seem to care about
only world of amoral at all and that's
kind of where it really kind of seems
like Marvel in general that you guys
don't really seem to care too much about
and it kind of sucks because there's
some all-new all-different marvel stuff
that I really dig that I really enjoy
but you know that's that's fine but I've
been working around trying to find a way
to essentially make this work and I
think that what we're going to do which
by the way now
I'm finally editing this hold on uh
doing this live as long as kind of weird
okay um the email address the giveaway
the giveaway email address is in the
description so you can refresh if you
want to and you'll see the the address
and there anyway um so the other we're
back on track
[Music]
Joshua Cook my parents would have been
proud I appreciate that I'd like to
think they would I like to think my
parents would have been really really
proud about what what's been achieved on
this channel but anyway so I upload a
video and I look at the comments that I
look at the views and those two things
give me an idea of what it is that you
guys do and do not like case in point
the Incredible Hulk I had been will
brown thank you for the donation I have
been wanting to cover the Incredible
Hulk for quite some time which by the
way send an email to that email address
and just put rock or ring in the subject
that's fun um anyway I've been wanting
to cover the Incredible Hulk for quite
some time and the reason why is because
of the fact that I love The Incredible
Hulk concept I love the Incredible Hulk
character is one of my favorite things
and I've been wanting to do greg packs
run but I didn't know how you guys would
respond to and I did not want to do
Planet Hulk and then World War Hulk and
then just stopped because nobody cared
so I figured we'd try it out a little
bit so we did a video more The
Incredible Hulk kills the Marvel
Universe and that video got you know
something like 300,000 views overnight I
was like okay you guys dig that so then
we did Planet Hulk you guys love that we
did what we're hope you guys love that
too so when we did the rest of reg packs
run and it's one of the most successful
you know series here on my channel and
so because of that I started going
through and I would upload videos and
look to see what it is that people do
and don't care about and what I've
noticed is that there seems to be very
little interest in all-new all-different
marvel and so there's maybe a handful of
stories that I want to finish out maybe
a handful of stories that I want to do
and then after that we're switching back
over to just old stuff and comic story
is doing a video about this like Vinny
is going to be doing a video some wonder
that's where he's going to be addressing
the same kind of issue Wow Jacob Hester
thank you so much for your channel
theory your channel I was able to
connect with my brother a huge kind of a
fan in a way that I didn't think
possible keep you
you keep making videos that's the whole
point man like that's the whole point of
the channel I'm glad you were able to do
that like I'm glad you were able to get
that connection because that's the goal
is to like giving you guys an idea of
what in the heck is going on in comics
so you're not you're not uh you're not
running blind so you don't feel so
totally lost hey Rob
thanks for all your awesome content that
has helped get my nephew into comics I
always look forward to your videos thank
you
that is awesome speaking of Wow more
Hulk buy yourself some coffee and get to
work you Big Bear I am like a Big Bear I
had a girl tell me that one she's like
Rob you're like a big teddy bear and I
was like yes I am uh and then yeah and
then okay nevermind that conversation
stops there anyway um so so speaking of
giving you guys a good idea of where to
start if we're going to be switching
over to classic Marvel stuff um I mean
we've got to do it we got to finish out
amazing spider-man
uh you binge watch my videos I
appreciate that um if we are going to do
classic Marvel stuff well right now I've
got mass fractions Iron Man which is
basically Iron Man like the secret
origin of Tony Stark stuff like that
we're going to do that then we're going
to do spotlight probably spider-verse
and then everything up to like all-new
all-different amazing spider-man and
then from there we're just going to come
jump into classic stuff you know I mean
in all honesty um I really want to cover
for like I really want to cover Thor
stories because I love Thor stories I
don't know how many of you guys were
reading for uh weightless on the water
from our world war rebirth and the huge
gaping burps um I don't have any of you
guys read Thor but Thor has some amazing
stories it really all goes back to like
Ragnarok um after Ragnarok J michael
Straczynski took over and then you
basically get the return of Thor and
that's where like Thor basically
resurrects like all the Asgardians
that's where like Loki becomes a chick
it's pretty cool it's pretty amazing
it's a great storytelling
um but yeah like I think we're gonna
we're gonna do God butcher because I
know that Vinnie is doing God which are
when the Thor movie comes out so I want
to have mine done out of the way because
I want to cover it and then when the
Thor movie comes out we're going to
start with Ragnarok and work up to God
what you're
and then be and then be done but God
Bush is probably one of the best runs on
on Thor my life is priceless
I'm glad you enjoy my laugh I never
really cared about my laugh too much
yeah I mean I'll do secret Empire when
it's done but the other half of this and
the one thing do you have a design for
the rockport ring yes I do ease again
thank you
I definitely have a design umm swag
kappa 101 are you hype for a negative
flash oh my god amateur some huh man I'm
right for that negative flash I am so
excited for the negative flash I think
it's going to be pretty stellar but one
of the things for example that through a
lot of people off is like the x-men um
okay here's a question for you guys who
are watching this right now and those of
you guys who are watching this
presumably later on how many of you guys
get thrown off and/or are confused by
what to read about the x-men after house
of M because that is what confuses the
heck out of people so bad uh the button
yeah the button was amazing and justice
to comic yes and justice to is coming me
me me me me me yes I hate that remember
it Nicholas had to be that one guy who's
just like I hate x-men
hey Rob any chance any chance you could
do a video on DC 1 million storyline
yeah I want to do that at some point um
but see here's here's a crazy thing is
like yep where to go so on and so forth
um yes Wow a lot of folks are confused
confused marry you I'm sorry I can't I
really can't okay so here is the deal
the x-men are you're confused to the
x-men House of M ok so here's the deal
what confuses people about the x-men is
they read house of M like egoraptor over
at game grumps poses question on Twitter
one day they read house of M and they're
like okay I read house of m and it was a
great story now I want to read the x-men
where do I go from here well let's go
and let's look online and then they see
like uncanny x-men and x-force of
x-factor and new x-men and all these
different
cable and so on and so forth Rob I have
more classic Batman oh I got to have
more classic Batman became already
please my channel rocks thank you
Rick and Morty was kind of interesting
but it lost me after a little while and
really it's from what I've noticed with
regards to the new 52 Batman it does
pretty well but we're going to like
after we're done with new 52 you we're
going to do like more DC we were stuff
and we're actually gonna be Wonder Woman
just because of the fact the movies
coming out and Wonder Woman rebirth is
amazing but anyway all the x-men titles
are what throw people love okay that is
the mistake do not look at the x-men
titles as individual books as individual
stories that you can read by themselves
no they are all basically events so here
is the chronology because I had gone
through how was up until 1:30 in the
morning last night putting this together
uh you cry every time from the rundown
videos um Wow uh Ryan Flannigan thank
you for for ten bucks I appreciate it J
scythe this ring will be the best thing
coming out of DC breath right now
you know it will be you know this ring
is gonna be the best thing coming out of
DC rebirth right now okay so I was up
until Wow Justin Estrada thank you for
one thank you one more time for helping
me beef up my trade paper that
collection still one of the coolest and
most unexpected things to ever happen to
me nagpur for life right poor for life
thank you so much fear itself yes fear
stuff will be covered once we start
doing the classic Thor stories from
Ragnarok going forward that will happen
because I've seen you guys asking for it
and so we are going to do it the problem
with fear itself is you can't just do
for yourself because there's things that
tie into fear itself that require us to
know what happened before fear itself so
I was up until 1:30 in the morning
putting this list together alright the
way the x-men comics go is you have to
read them as events alright so you have
really you have like half of them and
decimation and then you have a story
called x-men deadly Genesis how many of
you guys have heard of Vulcan the third
summer's brother the omega-level mutant
uh as again also the only good thing
coming
a new marvelous infamous Ironman Jane
Foster know where they thought I'm
worthy Thor was pretty amazing
how do people think Cyclops is evil do I
think he's evil all these evil but I
think he's kind of a bad guy I'm the
Morgan Freeman of YouTube I appreciate
that
you have you wish you you wish you
hadn't
Vulcan is a third summer's brother and
he's an omega-level mutant all right so
after how Savannah you had a story
called x-men deadly Genesis a Tech's
been deadly Genesis introduced the third
Sommers brother but was also the
resurrection of Charles Xavier after
house of M after that it's just
storylines endangered-species Messiah
Complex divided we stand manifest
destiny Messiah war utopia nation X so
on and so forth second coming all the
way down until you get to x-men
Regenesis and then the heroic age and
that's when you can start picking what
it is you want to read so we are going
to go through and we're probably gonna
do x-men maybe after Thor I'm not sure
yet
I want to fit it in somewhere we might
just kind of test the waters with x-men
but Charles Tyner thank you keep it up
brah I will but but I definitely want to
I'm gonna start getting into classic
stuff I want to test the waters and see
if that's what people care about because
at the end of the day I'm in the
business of running a channel you know
I'm in the business of running a
successful channel that's that's how we
got to 1 million and that's how I want
to stay you know above 1 million that's
well how I want to keep my channel
growing um you know if I upload a video
and you guys just don't really watch it
then it means you guys just don't really
care about it and there's no sense in me
continuing to upload videos you guys
just don't really care about and so
because of that we're going to test the
waters with classic Marvel stuff um with
DC it's the opposite I was testing the
waters with new 52 and it does well but
it doesn't do as well as DC rebirth and
I think the reason because of that or
the reason why is because people don't
have any reason to want to read new 52
because they're just like DC rebirth is
amazing you know there are some stories
that we could do like the reason why we
tested the waters with new 52 Batman is
because Scott Snyder was talking about
Batman metal and how a lot of it also
goes all you know goes all the way back
to his run on Batman and so I figured we
would just do the new 52 run and just
kind of call it a day and see what
happens but after this we're just going
to jump into you know jump back in a DC
rebirth and discover DC Weber stuff and
what we're also going to do is we're
going to go back to doing one video a
week just because of the fact that over
the course of the next month I'm going
to be moving and so I'm not going to
have the time or the energy to record
two videos a day and get them up I'm
going to be like packing and I'm going
to be moving Benny and I are probably
gonna be doing a road trip so yeah it's
going to be kind of kind of packed with
all the stuff we're going to have going
on but um I have not had a chance to
watch the class a flash last night which
I need to but but yeah so anyway um
honestly we'll probably just cover like
all the DC Weaver stuff and just go from
there I mean I would really see a reason
to like kind of like be spotty on DC we
probably just cover it all because
there's a lot of things we haven't done
yet I mean on DC we breath because you
guys don't know this but I keep a
massive spreadsheet of all the stories
that I've done and all the stories that
are coming out
hey big bigger congratulations on
reaching 1 million subscribers on your
channel have you played the injustice 2
game yet and who is your favorite the
flash is my favorite I love the Flash's
character I love how he moves and I love
how fast he is in his maneuvers he's
pretty cool drew Alexander thank you for
for five bucks I appreciate that um but
like okay so we have not covered we
covered that we covered everything in
Action Comics except volume 1 which is
where Superman fought doomsday we have
not covered also our Batman we have not
covered Batgirl birds of birds of prey
we've not covered Batgirl we haven't
done bat woman rebirth we haven't done
Blue Beetle we haven't done Justice
League of America we haven't done
Suicide Squad we haven't done Supergirl
we haven't done superwoman we haven't
done Teen Titans we haven't done the
Hellblazer
there's a lot of stuff that we haven't
done yet and so there's a lot of videos
out there for us to be able to do you
know and keep things going for a while
so I think we're going to do that so I
think that's how things are going to go
for the foreseeable future the very
least until August you know we test the
waters um we're going to do a classic
Marvel and we're going to stick with DC
rebirth that is kind of good and I'm
going to I'm just going to gauge
reactions I'm going to see how you guys
respond to stuff it could be that just
no one cares about Marvel whether it's
classic Marvel whether it's new Marvel
no one cares at all that could very well
be the case it could be that they're
just no one cares in any form or fashion
you know I have no idea it would be very
expensive to do a spectrum movie right
now I don't think so no more expensive
than like an Avengers movie or Iron Man
movie or any
like that I don't think so I don't know
but yeah I could just be that people
just don't care about we're going to
test the waters we're going to
experiment we're going to find out and
we are going to stick with classic
Marvel for the foreseeable future with
the exception of a couple stories here
in there so anyway guys uh we're going
to wrap this up we're gonna mess up and
kind of close it down unless you guys
have questions you want me to answer
um unless you omitted you know talk to
you guys about stuff I don't know see
what you guys think I don't but I mean I
have a gaming channel but I've never
really I mean I had it for a little
while but I kind of got bored of video
games so I just no really worried about
it um but yeah so this century notice me
before you leave some pie Ethan yes I
noticed you Ethan love Marvel never stop
does Bruce wayne/batman know he's in
pots man but alright let me my guys I'm
gonna go ahead and and bounce off here
Orlando
thank you Ron for your great insight
thank you for watching
Wow what up Rob what's our emotion was
our Rob poor emotional spectrum swag hey
oh I didn't tell you guys about that
okay so so I meant to tell you guys
about that um alright so here let's go
let's go check this out alright let's go
check the phone alright so if you go to
my Twitter account
here's here's what you'll find you'll
find here's the Rob for stuff that you
will find um let's sign in and let's
look at it okay so our phrase alright
our whole thing is you have the desire
to know all things
welcome to the Rob core alright now
here's here's our here's our Lantern
oath alright here's our Rob port of from
pages small to green of brights no comic
shall escape my sight let those who
choose a side and fight be one of the
power of rockers lights all right that
is our ode which i think is a really
cool and one of you guys were the one
who made that up you guys actually want
to contest to to create the the Rob for
Lantern oath all right um
here are the abilities of the Rob pour
ring all right no yeah it's an awesome
earth all right here are the abilities
of the Rob program the Rob pour rain can
perform all the same functions of a
standard Lantern ring including flight
and the ability to generate hardlight
constructs the Rob core ring holds all
knowledge of past events and current
events currently happening across the
universe as well as those evolved and
their abilities and powers now the
weaknesses the rock or ring has no
effect on the powers or abilities of
other Lantern rings meaning it can't
like nullify like a Red Lantern ring or
it can't cure a person of the Red
Lantern rage or anything like that
if the wielder of a rope or ring loses
concentration I've lost my place this is
concentration they will be overwhelmed
by their knowledge and go insane the
more arrogant a wielder of the rock or
the more arrogant a wielder of the rock
or ring becomes the weaker their
constructs become if a wielder of the
rock or ring becomes too arrogant the
ring will leave and seek out a new host
let's see now the caveat to this is that
if a person is selected to join the Rob
Corps they can reject the ring after
which it'll seek out somebody else so um
yeah that's I think I think it's cool I
think it's a really cool a really cool
thing
so the Rob Corps war at the Rob for
Civil War may be kind of crazy that'd be
pretty wild
but you lose concentration often he lose
concentration all the time anyway
yeah secret Empire will be coming out at
the end of like when it finishes I will
do that but anyway um alright guys I'm
going to go ahead and bounce off here
I'm going to go through and finish you
know organizing all this stuff and
record some videos and yeah I will catch
you all later peace